Freddy Fazbear the animatronic singing
bear and Main mascot for Freddy
Fazbear's pizzeria was brought into
existence in 1983 we know this from the
year printed on the coins in the game
Five Nights at Freddy's help wanted the
1980s the Golden Age of the pizza Arcade
kids all over America were flocking to
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza the only place
where you can Chow Down on a mids slice
of pepperoni and throw quarter after
quarter into an 8bit video game like Miz
Pac-Man one such kid was a regular Preen
known only to us as Gabriel Gabriel
loved the pizza and the games but what
brought him back to Fazbear's pizzeria
was truly their animatronic mascot
state-of-the-art at the time they could
sing they could dance they could well
that was pretty much it but Gabriel
loved it welcome to Freddy's have you
met them
yet met
who
foxy Bonnie Chica and Freddy Bonnie
Chica and Foxy were fan favorites but
Gabriel loved Freddy the oversized
animatronic bear with a black hat and
bow tie he admired Freddy he loved
Freddy and and it was a good thing he
did because after Gabriel's horrific
murder Gabriel became Freddy a version
of Freddy out for Revenge a Freddy that
sliced up more than just pizzas and a
Freddy who had no problem saying game
over to your
[Music]
life Welcome to Horror history one of
this year's most anticipated films is
Five Nights at Freddy's based on the
popular video game and media Empire
created by Scott cin cin wrote the film
and has been the creative lead behind
the FNAF Games sequels spin-offs novels
guide books and the rest of the Fazbear
Empire the Freddy mascot from the Five
Nights at Freddy's Universe ironically
became the mascot for the entire
multimedia franchise and although he has
delivered some memorable scares I
wouldn't call him the main antagonist of
the series in order to fully understand
how a creepy robot from a decade past
became one of the most feared
supernaturally possessed horror gaming
icons we have to dig deep into the
history of Fazbear entertainment Inc and
it's original owners William Aton and
Henry
Emily the evil begins as it does in many
stories with a British person William
Aton the co-founder of Fazbear's
pizzeria and Gabriel's eventual killer
was a calm sophisticated Brit hiding an
array of Psychopathic Tendencies he's
seen as a manipulative and focused
businessman with the goal of building a
pizza franchise Empire sometime in the
early 1970s William Aton created Aton
robotics LLC this would soon combined
with his interest in entertainment
dining facilities in the late 1970s
William Aton met another entrepreneur
named Henry Emily and the two
collaborated to form their first
entertainment dining facility aimed at
children called fredbears Family Diner
this original Diner was much more
reminiscent of the establishments
Chuck-E-Cheese and ShowBiz Pizza which
was a direct rival to Chuck-E-Cheese in
my Horror history episode on Charles
entertainment cheese it was noted that
around this time period in the early
1980s Chuck-E-Cheese wasn't doing well
and many knockoff Children's
Entertainment diners were popping up
mimicking the layout of their
restaurants and using their own band of
anthropomorphized animals who sing and
perform show pizza and fredbear's Family
Diner were two such ripoffs but where
showbiz's pizza would Fade Into
Obscurity fredbear's Family Diner would
gain a far more Insidious reputation
where Charles found himself in the Seedy
underbelly of Children's Entertainment
with drugs gambling debt and internet
hoaxes Freddy Fazbear gets into an even
more demented world of Children's
Entertainment this restaurant centered
around fredbear and a yellow rabbit
character named spring Bonnie fredbear
was in a sense the original Freddy
Fazbear however he would go on to take a
whole new form after fredbear's Family
Diner went out of business under
mysterious circumstances I think the
name of the place was fredbears Family
Diner or something like that it was
closed for years though I doubt we'll be
able to track anybody down as time goes
on fredbear and spring Bonnie would gain
new friends Chica the backup singer
chicken and Foxy the pirate who if you
haven't figured it out yet is a fox all
of these characters look like they
really could have participated in the
robot pizza wars of the 1980s 80s in
1983 it's believed that William aton's
oldest son killed his youngest by
holding him up to the mouth of the
Freddy fazbar animatronics phase the
little boy who was scared of Freddy was
crying in fear his tears caused the
spring lock mechanism to malfunction and
Freddy's mouth to bite down on the boy's
head crushing it this tragedy or one
like it is the cause of afton's
murderous and Psychopathic Tendencies
under that corporate facade lies an
egotistical satus who doesn't just want
to kill his victims but designs their
deaths to ensure that they physically
suffer first it's not about the killing
it's about causing pain in others where
the sadism comes from is Up For Debate
but many FNAF scholars believe that
Afton was irreparably changed from the
loss of his son fredbear's Family Diner
only stayed open for a few years after
this incident but just long enough for
William Aton to kill his first known
victim Charlotte Emily the daughter of
fredbear family Diner's co-owner Henry
Emily but this is where the first puppet
is possessed as Charlotte possesses a
puppet that had been programmed by her
father to protect her although this
would all lead to the closure of the
original fredbear family Diner this
wouldn't be the end of the company or
the iconic character Freddy would evolve
and take on many different variations
and forms which I'll discuss more at the
end of this lesson but for the sake of
our timeline let's just focus on the two
main forms classic Freddy and withered
Freddy as the original fredbears Family
Diner closed the original Freddy mascot
was stored in the back of a new
restaurant Freddy Fazbear's Pizza where
he would be known as withered Freddy the
new restaurant was off to an actually
okay start until William aton's sadistic
side allowed itself to
emerge but William Aton murderous
Tendencies didn't stop there and soon
Gabriel and four other innocent children
would become his next
victims Gabriel was a 10-year-old boy
with bushy brown hair who visited
fredbear's Family Diner in June of 1985
it's heavily implied that the well-
behaved Gabriel was at the restaurant to
celebrate one of his friends birthdays
little is known about Gabriel because at
the end end of the day Gabriel could
have been any 10-year-old when Aton
killed him it wasn't because of who he
was it was about the act of hunting and
killing him on the night of June 26 1985
Gabriel and His Friends Jeremy Susie
Fritz and Cassidy were approached by one
of the restaurant's big Goofy mascots
spring Bonnie what they didn't know is
that inside the spring Bonnie costume
was William Aton and he was luring them
into a trap Aton invited the group of
kids into the back rooms no not those
back rooms the back rooms of the
Pizzeria and the five children found
themselves in a darkened room alone with
the British Pizza Mogul Afton shut the
door behind them and pulled out a knife
his weapon of choice in short order Aton
had stabbed and murdered five innocent
children some kids went missing it's why
the place shut
down the police searched Freddy's hey
they never found the
kid attempting to cover up his crimes he
stuffed their bodies into the empty
space inside the very same animatronics
that the kids came to fredbear's Family
Diner to admire inside the Freddy
Fazbear animatronic the restaurant
headliner and mascot he shoved the body
of little Gabriel the next morning Aton
told police that no one was allowed to
touch the animatronics so their bodies
were never found despite customer
complaints of smells mucus and blood
throughout the restaurant while Aton
avoided criminal prosecution for these
murders eventually known as the missing
children incident people began to
suspect that he was somehow involved in
the kid's disappearance and the
pizzeria's business began to suffer but
that turned out to be the least of his
problems The Souls of the children that
Aton had killed lingered in the mascot
suits and instead of moving on to the
afterlife they stayed on Earth and
eventually learned how to control the
same animatronics that their bodies had
been stuffed into when Gabriel was alive
he was a mild-mannered polite child but
after his murder he became vengeful and
enraged once he learned how to control
the Fazbear animatronic Gabriel saw this
newfound power as an Avenue to get
revenge on the man that killed him and
hopefully then move on from the mortal
world Jeremy Susie Fritz and Cassidy
shared a similar goal with their ghosts
inhabiting the other animal animatronics
Bonnie Chica foxy and golden Freddy
while it's not mentioned exactly what
year fredbear's Family Diner was shut
down it seems likely that it happened
shortly after the murders this does not
stop Aon and now working on his own he
opens a new location in early November
of 1987 going by the date on the
paycheck you receive in Five Nights at
Freddy's 2 however in this new location
Freddy is given a makeover and is back
to looking like his classic self along
with the others these new versions of
Freddy and his friends used a different
technology than the others they were
actually animatronic suits that had what
was referred to as a spring lock
mechanism allowing them to operate as
both an animatronic and bodysuit in
animatronic mode the characters could
move on their own but in bodysuit mode
the machinery would be pulled back
allowing a person to step inside and
wear it like a costume it is here in
1987 that the first incidents of Freddy
Fazbear and the other possessed
animatronics openly demonstrate an urge
to kill and even though their goal was
to get revenge on William Aton as soon
as nightfalls they'll go after any adult
in the building which is usually the
security guards who protect the pizzeria
during the off hours it's speculated
that as lingering Spirits they they
can't differentiate one human from
another all that well they just see a
tall man wearing the purple security
guard uniform and Associate that with
William Aton who was wearing purple at
the time that he killed them they
interact with the kid just fine but when
they encounter an adult they just stare
Freddy Fazbear is the lead murder robot
taunting his victims and maliciously
stalking them like Aon before him
Fazbear enjoys killing and shows his own
streak of sadism as he does
it as the new restaurant was opened to
thwart the bad reputation of the prev
location they put out an ad in the local
paper to hire new night guards and
attempt to shift the public view of this
new location as a positive thing listing
it as Vintage Pizzeria given New Life
using the word vintage is particularly
funny considering that the other
Pizzeria was only closed at the most
like 2 years previous to this anyway we
never learned who the first guard was to
answer the ad but we know that it did
not take long before Freddy and Company
must have come for him because he almost
immediately requests to be moved to the
dayshift according to the phone message
left for his night shift replacement
Jeremy Fitzgerald you're only the second
guard to work at that location uh the
first guy finished his week but
complained about conditions the hiring
manager also suggests a number of
temporary solutions in dealing with the
characters one of which is for Jeremy to
wear a Freddy Fazbear mask in order to
confuse them which initially throws them
off but even that only does so
much Aton and his company are able to
keep Freddy's murders a secret for a
while but eventually Freddy and others
start attacking during the day the
restaurant is closed and somehow Jeremy
isn't given this information and is
locked inside with Freddy and his
friends for one last night so after just
a few weeks Freddy Fazbear's Pizza is
closed and the attacks are covered up as
new animatronics malfunctioning
according to a story that the company
had printed in the paper this cover up
Works a new location is opened in the
early 1990s and the crimes of the
previous location seem to be buried this
time the animatronics from the previous
location are scrapped and the originals
from fredbear's Family Diner are
refurbished making withered Freddy the
new Freddy it's never specified if
Gabriel can possess multiple animatronic
suits at one time or if it's just the
one that his body was stuffed into but
either way this new form of Freddy is
out for Revenge under what seems like
Gabriel's influence this time Jeremy the
night guard does not return this could
be for several reasons he may have been
killed during his last shift or he may
have just realized that it wasn't worth
risking his life for $20.10 of overtime
pay even factoring in the inflation
since 1987 that's the equivalent of $545
in today's money whatever happened
Jeremy does not return and a night guard
by the name of Mike Schmidt starts the
job in the early 1990s we don't have an
exact date for Mike's tenure but based
on inflation and what he receives as pay
compared to what Jeremy got for the same
position early '90s seems to track Mike
is deliberately kept in the dark on
Freddy in his past uh I wanted to record
a message for you to help you get
settled in on your first night um I
actually worked in that office before
you I'm finishing up my last week now as
a matter of fact once again all training
is done via voice message and while the
person on the phone does their best to
try to hide the fact that Freddy has
killed other guards he does slip up here
and there saying that he's surprised
that Mike has made it this far on just
the third night most people don't last
this long it seems this time the company
attempted to protect itself by
installing secure steel doors that the
guards could use to lock themselves into
the office when they see Freddy chica
Bonnie or foxy approaching which offers
a little more protection than just
putting on a bear costume and hoping
that they think that you're one of them
but the company has a limited
electricity budget meaning that Mike
couldn't keep the protective doors armed
the entire night and it wouldn't be long
before the roaming animatronics set
their sites on
[Music]
him Mike would do his best to monitor
the activity going on in the restaurant
during his Five Nights at Freddy's but
Freddy and the others were good at
sneaking past when the security cameras
were looking elsewhere along with the
other guards before Mike it seems as
though Freddy killed whoever it is that
is training him over the voicemails
because in the middle of the last one it
cuts out and what can be assumed is
Freddy's demonic voice is heard mumbling
gibberish leaving Mike on his own hey
wow day four I knew you could do it uh
Hey listen I may not be around to send
you a message tomorrow it's it's been a
bad night here for me um I'm kind of
glad that I recorded my messages for
you when I did hey do me a favor maybe
sometime uh you could check inside those
suits in the back room I'm going to try
to hold out until someone checks maybe
it won't be so bad yeah I always
wondered what was in all those empty
heads back there you
know oh
no according to the check stubs Mike did
make it through one more night and was
paid double his rate for overtime which
was only another $120 after this the
murdered children possessing the
animatronics finally stopped targeting
security guards long enough to go after
their main target William Aton in the
mid99s William Aton returned to the
dusty and shuddered Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza to dismantle his original
animatronic Creations the children's
ghost chased Aton into his safe room
where another unpossessed animatronic a
spring Bonnie had been placed for
storage fleeing the vengeful ghost Aton
jumped into the spring Bonnie suit to
hide but over the years the pizzeria
building had decayed and on that rainy
night leaks were plentiful one of these
leaks was right over the animatronic
that Aton was hiding in and soon enough
it shorted out its spring lock mechanism
according to these vintage instructional
tapes uncovered in F3 a spring lock
mechanism is a design inside of the
animatronic suit that allows a user to
pull a crank and lock the machine parts
so that the wearer won't be ripped apart
by the gears to change the animatronics
to suit mode insert and turn firmly the
hand crank provided by the manufacturer
turning the crank will recoil and
compress the animatronic parts around
the sides of the suit providing room to
climb inside please make sure the spring
locks are fast and tight to ensure the
animatronic devices remain fixed and
whoever created the instructional tapes
seems very aware of what can happen if
the instructions are not followed please
pay close attention while learning how
to operate these suits as accidents SL
injuries SL death SL irreparable and
grotesque Mings can occur when Aton
climbs into the suit in an instant the
robot's gears sprung shut on his body
mutilating him and causing an extremely
slow extremely painful death shortly
after the ghosts of the slain children
including Gabriel in the Freddy Fazbear
animatronic decided that they no longer
needed to inhabit their robot bodies and
moved on to the afterlife but the cycle
of violence continued Beyond just
Gabriel's inhabitation of Freddy Fazbear
for one Aton came to possess the spring
Bonnie robot that his body was now
enclosed in and became known as
springtrap another murderous animatronic
once Gabriel had moved into the
Afterlife Freddy himself took kind of a
backseat and isn't heard from again
until 30 years later after the last
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza had closed in
2023 a horror attraction based on the
restaurant's sorted history was opened
called Faz be's frights the horror
attraction Freddy is not heavily
featured in this attraction but a very
withered version of Freddy sits outside
of an office door shortly after this
Fazbear entertainment puts out a VR game
called the Freddy Fazbear virtual
experience where they embrace the idea
that their once beloved mascot has
turned into a horror icon and while it's
true that some stories associated with
our name were Loosely based on actual
events the majority of them were total
Fabrications from the mind of a complete
lunatic lawsuits pending but we aren't
above laughing at ourselves
ha ha ha that's why we have recreated
many of these completely fictitious
scenarios lies that you've been fed over
the last several years into a hilarious
VR game the virtual experience contains
the in Universe versions of FNAF 1
through 3 as well as some additional
game mode it's kind of like how the stab
movies are actual movies inside of the
scream franchise throughout the
experience it becomes evident that
William afton's soul is still out there
manifesting in the game as a new villain
known as glitch trap the release of this
game actually helped reinvigorate
interest in the Fazbear brand by
marketing the game as a horror
experience to adults they also reminded
them how much they loved the Fazbear
brand as kids which helped generate
interest in giving their own kids a
similar experience at least that's my
take on the events because it wasn't
long before a new entertainment center
called Freddy Fazbear's Pizza Megaplex
is built most likely in the mid to late
2020s it seems to have evolved from
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza almost 40 years
earlier it's kind of like a Discovery
Zone or Disney Quest basically a
high-end arcade play center hybrid
there's a new futuristic version of
Freddy called glamrock Freddy who
doesn't seem to be possessed but he does
appear to be sentient there you
are how odd your guest profile is
unknown to me who are you a little boy
named Gregory gets trapped in Freddy
Fazbear's Mega pizz Plex but this time
the security guard a woman who goes by
Vanessa is out to get Gregory and wants
to kill him this is because Vanessa is a
follower of William Aton whose Soul
still lingers around possessing various
animatronics this time Freddy takes on a
different role as his goal is to protect
Gregory from Vanessa and Aton and ensure
that the little boy makes it through the
night there's also a new threat to worry
about known as the tangle an
amalgamation of different animatronic
Parts with a Funtime Freddy head
although glamrock Freddy seems to be
more of a protagonist this time around
his overall role hasn't really changed
he was originally out to get revenge on
William Aton and notoriously caused harm
to security guards so maybe Freddy is up
to his usual Antics depends on how you
want to look at it as a horror villain
it's in my opinion that Freddy Faz bear
is at its core a lesson about the
dangers of not letting go of the past
Gabriel as Freddy Fazbear is consumed
with revenge for his murder taking the
lives of innocent night guards William
Aton killed the missing children because
he couldn't get over the trauma of
losing his own family if either of these
characters had simply left past in the
past the cycle of violence could have
stopped beyond that the FNAF series
itself is constantly looking back to the
past with 8-bit style mini games and a
restaurant setting that was huge 40
years ago it is most popular with an
audience of now adults who get to see a
spin on a familiar location from their
childhoods in Five Nights at Freddy's 3
random Nostalgia Hunters try to raid the
old Pizzeria for animatronics turning
themselves into new victims this concept
is probably once again directly inspired
by real life where Urban explorers and
animatronic archivists have raided old
Chuck e- cheeses strob Biz pizzas and
other similar establishments to document
and preserve these relics of the past
but the message that the franchise and
the Freddy Fazbear character delivers
may not have even been an intentional
one at least that's the conclusion I
came to after looking into the past and
into the mind of the game's original
[Music]
developer it seems likely that the
lesson about letting go of the past is
likely a subconscious one accidentally
delivered by the games Creator Scott cin
the 45-year-old developer was also born
at the perfect time to have spent his
formative years in the establishments
that Freddy Fazbear's Pizza is based on
in the'80s Freddy Fazbear more than
anything else is the copyright safe
version of Billy Bob rali of the Rocka
fire explosion the in-house animatronic
band seen in ShowBiz Pizza restaurants
from 1980 to 1992 even just his acute
knowledge of these Chuck-E-Cheese
knockoff ShowBiz Pizza demonstrates cn's
fascination with a specific screenshot
of the 1980s but intentional or not the
warning about holding on to the Past
couldn't be clear in the FNAF Universe
Revenge literally traps you trapping you
as a ghost here on Earth and as a
demonic spirit inside an animatronic
it's only until your soul learns to let
go that you find peace and move on and
if that never happens well you're doomed
to continue your murder spree forever
which seems to be the case for many in
the FFA verse because Freddy's train of
Games books and now movies shows no sign
of stopping the theme of not being able
to let go has even persisted in the
games themselves Scott cin developed the
first six main games in the series which
include FNAF 1 through 4 sister location
Pizzeria simulator and the spin-off
ultimate custom Knight all of which have
William Aton as the main overarching
antagonist of the series in 201 2019
Five Nights at Freddy's help wanted was
set to release this time being developed
by steel wool Studios while this was
originally just going to be a collection
of VR ports of the original games it
ended up including a story of its own
that mostly exists in the game subtext
in help wanted you play as a game tester
testing out the VR versions of the Five
Nights at Freddy's games which now exist
in universe as the Freddy Fazbear
virtual experience which I mentioned
earlier but the games contain this
glitch character named glitch trap who
most fans believe to be sort of a
digital incarnation of Afton at this
point a lot of fans felt that William
Aton story had been told and were hoping
to see a new antagonist for this new era
of FNAF the steel wool era but that's
not what happened even the movie series
seems to be holding on to the
franchise's Past rather than pushing
forward into new territory Scott coffin
said that his script is based on Five
Nights at Freddy's 1 and that he hopes
to turn the sequel games into their own
movies as well not that that's a bad
thing the only reason I point it out is
because it is a telling choice this will
be the third adaptation of that original
story in the movie Cannon Mike Schmidt
the guard from the original Five Nights
at Freddy's gets hired of as a night
guard and brings along his daughter
during his [__] I will work and you will
sleep I
understand give your head it seems as if
the movie Cannon will be separate from
the game cannon because in the movie the
animatronics are targeting Schmidt's
daughter trying to kill her and get her
to become one of that what do they want
they want to make her like them while it
seems that earlier iterations of Freddy
or Gabriel were more set on protecting
children it does track that Gabriel
looks to other children as a means of
companionship so that is my take on the
very convoluted history of Freddy
Fazbear and if this video came out on
time you guys will have received a
Freddy Krueger episode and a Freddy
Fazbear episode all in one month so let
me know if there are any other horror
Freddy's that I can cover before we wrap
this one up it wouldn't feel right not
to mention a few of the other forms of
Freddy Fazbear that I held off talking
about for simplicity's sake so just as
there are many different forms of
Chuck-E-Cheese including the Pizza Time
theater era The Tuxedo era the skater
era Etc there are also tons of alternate
looks for Freddy Five Nights at Freddy's
four takes place in a child's bedro room
and the player is attacked by Nightmare
versions of the animatronics one of
which is the very terrifying nightmare
fredbear it's widely believed in the
fandom that the child that you're
playing as is William aton's surviving s
Five Nights at Freddy's 2 introduces
many alternate forms such as toy Freddy
and Shadow Freddy which means we can
only assume that while Gabriel's body
was stuffed into one specific
animatronic he was able to somehow
inhabit the other Freddy robots the
original five games all contain an
alternate called Golden Freddy who very
little is known about he almost seems to
be a cross between the old school
fredbear and the redesigned Freddy
Fazbear the fifth game Five Nights at
Freddy's sister location gave us yendo
short for yellow endoskeleton bear a
very Terminator esque version of Freddy
Fazbear the last one I'll highlight is
Phantom Freddy from Five Nights at
Freddy's 3 a burnt partially destroyed
character that somehow survived the
40-year time Gap the alternate forms are
just another cool way that Fazbear
entertainment mirrored the unsettling
evolutions of its real world's
counterparts but if you want to fully
understand the world of the 1980s robot
Pizza mascots that gave way to the
creation of the Five Nights at Freddy's
franchise you need should check out my
Horror history on the rat himself
Charles entertainment cheese please it's
probably my best video I feel like it
should have like at least four times
more views remember to subscribe to C's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell for all notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both
survive